الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بتهمة قتل قائد فيلق القدس
القادم بترافع اول محام روبوت
مدعم بالذكاء الاصطناعي في
كاليفورنيا وفيضانات قطعت
الكهرباء وعمليات اجلاء في
الفريق قاسم سليماني. سيشهد
العالم فريدة من نوعها في فبراير
والعشرين. ظهر كرم العراقيين
بولائم تقدم مجانا للجماهير.
اي تخفيف يتحدث. هل سيصغي لطلبات
مواطنيه لا زلنا في اوروبا ولكن
ثلاثة اسابيع من الاضرابات بسبب
وضع ناشطين من الاقلية الصربية
يحتجز جثامين اكثر من ثلاثمائة
وسبعين شهيد. اعلنت الشرطة ان
المنطقة بسبب عاصفة شديدة.
القضاء العراقي يأمر بالقبض على
حواجز على الطرق رفضا لقرارات
حكومة برشتينا. الاحداث
والتطورات. في ذكرى يوم الشهيد
الفلسطيني لا يزال الاحتلال
هدنة زجاجية ما برحت اطيافها
بالبدء حتى كسرت اصوات الصواريخ
ويخرج قائلا ان حكومته مصممة على
تخفيف الضغوط على قطاع الصحة فعن
تدني مستوى الخدمات الصحية. وفي
بريطانيا الحلم البعض يا باشا.
المحاكم للمرة الاولى في قضية
مرورية في كأس الخليج الخامس
والمدافع زجاجها ليعلن التدخل
برأيكم هل ينجح الرئيس التركي
الى شوارع باريس. تزامنا مع
تصعيد حركة الاضراب العمالية في
امانا. هنا احتجاجات على الاوضاع
المعيشية. السترات الصفراء تعود
النقابات برفع اجور الموظفين
والعمال بسبب غلاء المعيشة في
مختلف ارجاء فرنسا ودخول الاطباء
في اعتصام مفتوح احتجاجا على
النيتو يمسولتم بيرج ان تلامي
التعاون العسكري بين روسيا
حيث تستمر الاضرابات في البلاد
في عدة قطاعات حيوية. لتطالب
البلاد نتيجة للتضخم. ليشهد رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسون كيمته
البحرية للولايات المتحدة ان
المدمرة نفذت عملية عبور عبر
مضيق تايوان من اجل الالتزام
بامن منطقة المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ. هناك نشرت الصين قواتها
لتعلن معارضتها وبشدة. فهل حان
والفوضى تعم البلدان كانت حتى ما
قبل تلك العقوبات هي الاكثر
فيرجينيا. اعلان حالة الطوارئ
والاستجابة السريعة في
بجانب اليابان يجرون مناورات
جوية وبرية مشتركة. لتعلن القوات
وقت المواجهة? فوضى اوروبية. حرب
اوروبا الباردة ضد روسيا تفتح
التجارب الصاروخية لكوريا
الشمالية لتصرخ اليابان مستنجدة
النيران على الاوروبيين
وحكوماتهم وليس على الروس.
طفلا في السادسة من العمر اطلق
النار على معلمته في ولاية
في الجنوب الشرقي عاد الهدوء
الحذر الى شمالي كوسوفو بعد
بالحلفاء. هنا الولايات المتحدة
وبريطانيا والهند واستراليا
اليابانية. الصين تزعج اليابان
بالتحركات العسكرية لتزيد طينهم
ينامون بل ويسرقون النوم من اعين
اعدائهم. نعم يا اصدقاء فالتقارب
والصين يهدد النظام العالمي.
القلق والتوتر تنتقل للمفاصل
الصيني الروسي بات يأخذ منحى
خطيرا في الاشهر الاخيرة وهو امر
رسالة واضحة من موسكو لواشنطن
عليكم بانفسكم ولا تتدخل فيما لا
يخصكم. الصين تلعبها بذكاء.
اصحاب العيون يخططون ويعملون ولا
يثير مخاوف الدول الغربية بشكل
لافت. صرح الامين العام لحلف
السيبرانية. اذ صعدت من عمليات
القرصنة ضد كييه وحلفائها في
الصيف. حيث استهدف فريق قراصنة
روس يدعى النهر البارد ثلاث
اوكرانيا لذلك فالهزيمة ليست
خيارا له ولن يتنازل عن المقاطعة
منشآت نووية امريكية متخصصة في
الابحاث النووية وفقا لرويترز في
بسلام كهذا? فيما قال قائد قوات
كييف والكساندر بافيليو ان
القوات الروسية تستعد لشن هجوم
قوي اخر على العاصمة كييف
التي ضمها. ومن ارض المعارك
الاوكرانية الى الحرب
وللتصدي لمثل هذا الهجوم فانهم
يعملون على اقامة خطوط دفاعية
هي انشاء الامبراطورية الروسية
ولكن لا يمكن حدوث ذلك من دون
للوساطة من اجل سلام دائم بين
كييف وموسكو. ليعود الزينسكي
تدفق الاسلحة الغربية سيجعلكم
تفقدون اراضيكم امامنا ليرد
فرنسا تزويد قوات كييف مركبات
المشاة القتالية قد يؤدي لصدام
السابقة ووزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق ان مهمة بوتين الاساسية
الوقت ليس في صالح حيث قالت
وزيرة الخارجية الامريكية
وخيم السجال على الهدنة التي
اعلنتها روسيا ها هو الرئيس
بطول الف كيلومتر حول كييف. لكن
المخضرمين الامريكان يرون ان
بالظهور مجددا ويقول ان طرد من
وصفهم بالمحتلين الروس من كامل
التركي اردوغان يجري اتصالين
احدهما مع بوتين والاخر مع
الاراضي الاوكرانية سي السلام
والامن لبلاده. فهل يقبل الروس
في قتل المدنيين دفع الغرب الى
دعم اوكرانيا. وبعد ان تواصل
الروسية الاوكرانية فهل يكتب
الروس اول سطورها? جاء الرد
الروسي فورا على لسان السيناتور
الكسي بوشكوف الذي قال ان قرار
مباشر بين روسيا وحلف الناتو.
روسيا تحذر الاوكران. استمرار
ارسال واحدة من اكثر الهدايا
التي يرغب بها زلينسكي ليعلن
الزينسكي ليؤكد اردوجان لنظيره
الاوكراني ان بلاده مستعدة
مستشار رئاسة الاوكرانية ميخائيل
بودوليا قائلا ان الامعان الروسي
اورسي وفق تيليجراف البريطانية
لتنضم المانيا الى القافلة وتعلن
باتريوت للدفاع الجوي هذه
الاسلحة تفتح صفحة من كتاب الحرب
تزويد الاوكران بمركبات مشاة
قتالية من طراز ماردير وانظمة
ماكرون عن تزويد كييف بمركبات
مدرعة او دبابات اي ام اكس تن
الاراضي الاوكرانية. هناك خرج
امين عام حلف الناتو ينسون بيرج
الى الهدنة والتي كانت اشبه
بالمخدر لتنتهي اول هدنة معلنة
نعم يا سادة بوتين استخدم
استراتيجية الارض المحروقة. لنعد
دونيتسك. ليعلن الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان الهدنة التي
خلال ذلك. لي حين دور الانتقام
باعلان وزارة الدفاع الروسية
بقدراتها. وقبل ذلك ها هي
المساعدات العسكرية التي حذرت
الاتهامات باستمرار اطلاق النار
لتعلن اوكرانيا عن تعرض مدينة
باخموت للقصف الروسي خلال
الهدنة. كما اعلنت ان القوات
مصرحا ان روسيا لم تغير طموحاتها
في اوكرانيا ولا يجب الاستخفاف
منها موسكو بعد ان توسل الرئيس
الاوكراني الى الحلفاء طوال عام
منذ بداية الحرب وان كانت احادية
الجانب اوكرانيا وروسيا تتبادلان
الاعلان الروسي عن الالتزام
بالهدنة فان الدفاع الروسي اعلنت
اعلنتها روسيا لم تكن سوى كذبة
حيث واصلت القوات الروسية قصف
ان قوات كييف اطلقت النار احدى
وثلاثين مرة مقاطعة لترد قواتها
الاوكرانية حالت دون تنفيذ
الهدنة متهمة اياها بقصف
روسيا جيش بوتين الاسود اخترقوا
اخطر واهم قاعدة نووية في امريكا
على ترامب. فيما الكيان
الاسرائيلي يحتجز جثامين اكثر من
تقريبا لتسليمه دبابات غربية
والرئيس الفرنسي يوافق اخيرا على
على مصادر النيران وتدمرها معلنة
مقتل مئة وعشرين عسكريا اوكرانيا
الروسي حصد اكثر من ستمائة عسكري
اوكراني لقوا حتوفهم بضربة مدينة
لكن الهدنة ماتت قبل ان تولد
رسميا ويا فرح ما تمت. وبرغم
فيما الصين ترعب الغرب بهذه
الخطوة الذكية واليابان ترد
انها نفذت عملية عسكرية كرد على
مقتل جنودها في الاوكرانية. الرد
العصر الحديث. والكوارث تحل على
الامريكان والمحكمة تصدر امرا
قوات الاحتلال الروسي والناتو
يتأنى. بينما اردوغان يتدخل
للوساطة فهل ينجح فرنسا والمان
تقتربان من صدام عسكري مباشر مع
يدقون طبول الحرب ليبدأ بحفلة
الانتقام. والزينيسكي يرد سنطرد
اكثر مما خسروا يا بوتين فقد
اصبحت اوكرانيا كومة ركاب. الروس
بوتين انتم تدخلون رهانا خاسرا
وستخسرون الكثير. فماذا سيخسرون
تقبل بطلبات الغرب هذه المرة
واعلنت هدنة ولكن من طرف واحد
الانتقام الخبيث. الاتهامات تزيد
الضغوطات لتنال الطلبات. روسيا
ثلاثمائة وسبعين شهيدا فلسطيني.
مستعينة بالحلفاء. الاوروبيون
يعيشون فوضى لم يسبق لها مثيل في
فيما فشل